Rebel Wilson is opening up about the
rules that came along with being a
Barden Bella yes while sitting down with
Alex Cooper for the latest episode of
the call her daddy podcast Rubble
revealed that while filming the Pitch
Perfect movies which were released
between 2012 and 2017 she was under
contract to not lose or gain any weight
that's a long time to 2017. yeah that's
a lot now Rebel explained that because
of those parameters for her character
Fat Amy she wasn't able to kick-start
her health Journey until the Pitch
Perfect movie seemed like they were over
I did wait until Pitch Perfect seemed
like it was over I couldn't I couldn't
lose a massive amount of weight because
I was in the contracts for that movie
you can't lose I think it's more than
not more than 10 pounds or it's a real
gain more than 10 pounds yeah you have
to kind of stay at the weights like in
your contract
um and but I'd been thinking for a while
like oh I wanted to get healthier
um and I was stereotyped
um in playing that fat funny friend
which is so hard because I love those
roles like I mean I love doing the roles
I love those characters but then I did
want to do more things but I I felt like
um yeah being the bigger girl you're
just more more pigeonholed
however Rebel reassured Alex that she
wasn't offended by the role when the
script was brought to her and shared
that she loved playing that Amy
when I think about like Pitch Perfect
in the movie you your character calls
herself that Amy yeah and you're like
I'm gonna reclaim this name like if I
say it no one else can did someone write
that for you or did you come up with it
so well weirdly I'd played a character
called fat Mandy in Australia on a
sketch show
um where that character goes to Fat Camp
essentially and he's like Oh I thought
this was about celebrating fatness I
didn't know this Camp was to lose weight
like how is that and so it was a real
like body positive thing and then I got
sent in the script by K Cannon
um got back in the day over Facebook and
um and she sends me this script and goes
I hope you're not offended but the
characters called Fat Amy and I looked
at the script and I'm like what's she
talking about and then I read it and I
was like no Fat Amy I think is like the
best character in the whole movie like
of course I'd love to play it and um and
so and it really didn't offend I guess
no it's not it was like to me that was
kind of distinctive about the character
and I love playing her like so much and
like we called we had the best fun on
Pitch Perfect movies and to me like it
was just awesome to play her because
she's just so confident and ballsy
such a great character so good and I
love to hear about that she's not
looking back at a role like that and
being like you know I regret playing
this role or I feel differently about it
now like I love that someone who is
calling yourself Fat Amy she feels like
this was the best character she was so
confident she owns you she was like yeah
so I love hearing that however just like
the host of the podcast I'm like wait
that's a real thing in the contract you
can't gain or lose 10 pounds he's like
what I think we're we're kind of
accustomed to
thinking about
um actors and actresses
having to stay like really Slim or
really muscly for a role right but is
that would that even be in the contract
I I
haven't seen any of their contracts
right personally but I think that
there's I mean there's there's got to be
something I think when it comes to or
just an expectation an expectation right
that you're going to look at this
particular way whether it's healthy for
you or not because you're doing it uh
for the role but yeah to to hear that I
from her point of view I think was a
little surprising yeah and you know I've
talked about this before about you know
do we hear this a lot when it comes to
men in their contracts you know like
when they're playing these superheroes
they have to have this amount of muscle
versus this amount of fat like it just
doesn't seem like it's something that is
important when it comes to contracts
with men now once again I haven't seen
those contracts or I don't know yeah but
it seems I mean my contacts here clearly
states that I have to be like super
duper muscly yeah I can see it all the
time but yeah so it's just if that is
something that I find curious but I just
I I just think that sucks sometimes but
I understand this is a very specific
character I get listen but you know we
have seen other actresses and singers
and people in the entertainment industry
who have been one way for a long time
wait wise you know if you want to even
talk about that I hate talking about
weight
um and people like lizzo or Adele who
have decided to take a healthier
lifestyle and they're fans Mount Studios
not you know their fans get angry with
them they feel like they're either you
know becoming Hollywood or and they're
like guys I'm just trying to live a
healthier lifestyle so I feel sometimes
when there's still so much discussion
that I wish there wasn't when it comes
to women and their body absolutely you
know I think that
um when you are famous and you look a
particular way yeah people might see
themselves in you right right and they
find oh I'm being represented this way
by this person and that is a wonderful
thing to feel especially if they're on
side with you publicly right especially
if they don't see that a lot in
Hollywood right exactly and when you see
that person maybe go the other way it
can feel a bit like a betrayal or it can
feel like you said they were in
Hollywood or they're selling out but I
think at the at the end of the day
um whatever someone is doing for their
own well-being like we gotta accept this
is what the person wants to do and and
that's good for them I agree